we are delighted to have with us Vice
President of Ghana John Romano
Mohammed his Excellency Mihama has been
in politics for plus 15 years in the
Parliament and in the government in many
capacities from running the ministry
communication to founding the Ghana aids
Commission he's in fact a TL to attend
this participant the Yale global health
leaders Institute conference Excellency
Mihama welcome thank you
so the question I had before first of
all is during the conference you had the
opportunity to meet many of the fellow
African health officials as well as
other experts so on the challenges that
Africa faces in terms of disease today
and what are the plans for dealing with
them actually health as one area in
which Africa faces a lot of challenges
and a lot of resources have had to be
applied you know to try and deal with
some of the challenges we face I mean
from malaria to Tuba closest to hiv/aids
to maternal mortality to mental health I
mean just you name any sector which
which of these are the most important at
this point that is the point we have
determined what we think are the most
important and often it creates a
concentration on those ones to the
neglect of others that creates problems
for instance I mean 30 years ago the
world discovered hiv/aids and over the
last 30 has a lot of focus has been on
hiv/aids and so huge huge huge resources
have been put into the fight against
hiv/aids to the neglect of other areas
like malaria like mental health and so
on and so forth
and so even though malaria continues to
be a major killer the amount of money
and resources that have gone into
malaria I know we're up to one one
twentieth of the amount of money that
has gone in
to HIV and AIDS even though malaria has
been with us much longer it's only
recently that we are upscaling the you
know resources going into this areas and
so I don't like to put one health
challenge over the other I think all
health challenges are health challenges
that need to be dealt with and so we
should try and distribute resources you
know fairly across to see how we can
deal with a lot of these issues all very
happy to come and find that our team
working here had been working on mental
health mental health for instance is one
area we have neglected completely it is
a very stigmatized area families don't
want to own up to having mad people who
have mental challenges in their family
and so on and so forth and so I think
it's a whole new way of looking at
things
yeah talk about stigma the stigma
attached to homosexuality yeah it is a
major problem I gather in Ghana because
you have brought down the incidence of
AIDS but it has grown among this
community of people so how do you hope
to be stigmatized this aspect of life
that's a very very important question
and that's one of the areas that we are
looking at I mentioned it at a
conference we had in New York yesterday
that is a conference on hiv/aids we have
been successful in reducing the
prevalence level of hiv/aids generally
within our country has gone from about
3.6 percent to 1.5 percent over the last
ten years but we have hot spots and
these hot spots are commercial sex
workers we've been successful that we
brought the percentage prevalence rate
from 80 percent to 25 percent today but
then now there is the category of men
having sex with men there's a very
strong cultural hostility to
homosexuality in our society and so
often people are not willing to own up
to their sexual orientation and so the
these people are normally underground
it's difficult to identify who they are
as if called to reach them with
awareness is difficult to reach them
with treatment and so we are trying to
educate people to understand that we
need to remove stigma so that people can
come out you know of of hiding and be
able to say yeah this my sexual
orientation these are the problems I
have so that you can reach them where
the appropriate interventions that are
necessary for instance we have no
statistics as to how many people you
know and men having sex with men we
don't we don't have any statistics so
how do you educate them to media through
television the media is the most
important if you the various surveys
we've done in Ghana if you ask people
how do you receive information on
various things I mean anything health
education everything the first thing
they'll tell you maybe it's radio may be
followed by television and then after
that interpersonal communications and
all that so media is absolutely
absolutely
important and if you look at the nature
of our geography some areas that are
quite remote you can't send people there
but you can reach them by the radio
waves and so we do a lot of education
using radio and then with television and
then we also have community health
workers and others who know the
community and I able to reach that now
with motorcycles with bicycles or any
other appropriate means of
transportation here yeah you also have
another advantage now I think
particularly during your feed time as
the Minister of Communications Ghana has
really blossomed as a country with high
cell phone penetration so that gives you
another tool perhaps to reach out at the
time we started this whole telecom
liberalisation I mean I look back 10
years and it's breathtaking how far
we've come
you know nobody believed that we could
truly liberalize the sector and attract
the kind of investment that I've gone
into it mobile phone technology has
exploded across Africa I mean people
have taken to it like I mean remote
villages where we thought I mean if you
send this telecom nobody's going to have
the income to afford to even buy you
know credit to recharge a mobile phone I
mean
surprised you put a sell side to be and
tomorrow they're 200 subscribers in a
little village you know and so the
mobile phone has become a very important
you know means of tools of tool of
communication and it is one of the
platforms that we can use one to educate
people to to reach them with messages
you know and three to generally improve
the quality of their lives going forward
I surprised though that while you have a
sixty percent penetration in cell phone
Internet users only about 1.2 million
according to the strategy yeah how do
you explain this discrepancy between
high cell phone and very low Internet
yeah it's because initially the policy
we had in respect of rolling out
telecoms was at first just to give
people you know connectivity by voice
and so that was where our focus was and
so we concentrated a lot of you know
resources in building out the network
and all that and with Internet the major
problem was that we did not have enough
access we use I mean outmoded dial-up
modems and so on and so forth which were
slow and all that it made it very
difficult to access the net because our
we have sufficient broadband you know
access happily that situation is
changing we have all the telcos rolling
out their own internet we have
blackberry internet comes with their
mobile phones today and so you don't
need to go buy a laptop or you know to
have access a computer yes and so it's
beginning to expand rapidly to we had
just one submarine cable seven gamma
which was the submarine cable you know
controlled by Vodafone today there are
three more for submarine cables one by
glue one by main one one by MTN and
owned by Vodafone providing fast speed
broadband access and it comes with your
telecom service they just can put a
little antenna on top of your house and
you have high-speed service and so it's
you know increasing the penetration and
I'm sure that in the next five years we
will see you know quite a huge jump in
Internet penetration in Ghana in the
light of what we have seen in the Arab
Spring and you have written very low
currently about the Arab Spring
technology played a very important role
there and how do you see as Internet and
cell phone expands in Africa how do you
see this affecting American Africa's
political social life well for
sub-saharan Africa I think that the
changes that need to be made have
happened already we called it the
African relations I mean when African
countries that attend in around you know
military dictatorships were becoming a
thing of the past
most countries held national conferences
wrote constitutions and if you look in
sub-saharan Africa the bulk of countries
in sub-saharan Africa are constitutional
democracies I mean between 2010 and 2011
over a 12-month period 24 sub-saharan
African countries went to elections
successfully there might be a few
hiccups like whatever and so on but
largely I mean these were successful
elections and so for sub-saharan Africa
a lot of that revolution has taken place
already and so in the article I said we
should rather ask what effect
sub-saharan Africa has had on North
Africa in terms of what's what's
happening I think that social networking
tools have been important in providing
people with knowledge and awareness
today you cannot eternally suppress a
people and let them not know what is
happening in other parts of the world
except it's not Korea or something you
know otherwise in other parts of the
world where Internet
and the media you know television and
all that you know is it's available
people can see what's happening in other
parts of the world and so you can't
continue to suppress them
I one thing I always says we should not
overplay you know the role of you know
Internet and you know ICT in all this it
also has been you know the long
suppressed feeling of the people to be
able to live in dignity you know and so
it's a combination it's an interplay of
the two you know I think it's the
people's will to rise and live in
dignity combined with an instrument they
had to make you know communication
easier I think that's what that's the
issue of African Union African Union has
been rather ineffective if I must say in
the case of Libya and the case of Cote
d'Ivoire so what lessons would you draw
from these two episodes of what the
African Union should do to be more
effective I think that the African Union
is is it's important and still an
effective tool it was a union union that
brought us together formally as oau to
fight the liberation struggle from
colonial rule and it's finished that
mandate and so it was decided to change
its mandate and create the African Union
now the African Union is more for peace
security and integration of the African
continent that is s mandate it has done
well in creating the platform for
African leaders to discuss issues of
integration and all that and so I think
they've done fantastically made often
with issues of security we have the
Peace and Security Council you know in
the African you know that deals with
issues of conflict on the subcontinent
and if you consider that we share you
know how the problem is being solved
Liberia had a problem it's been sobs
early on had a problem has been solved
Guinea had a problem has been solved
Mauritania had a problem has been solved
I think that on the balance if you wanna
says the African Union it
and positive look I know use just call
Devon and Libya to judge that we cook
divine in Libya I would say that it is
also the rule the international
community played because the UN took an
interest in what was happening and as
you know a resolution was passed that
allowed you know airstrikes
you know in Libya and so while the
African Union was playing immediately
rule you know airstrikes had started to
happen already by the time the African
Union team was ready to land in Tripoli
the airport had been closed you know so
it took a while for them to be able to
go there they spoke together I think
enough you agree to a truce but
unfortunately the rebels say no we don't
want any truce and let's get our fees
out of the picture you know and so that
has created its own difficulties but I
think that the Libyan people I mean they
don't have to destroy their country
before they come to peace there should
be some dialogue that goes on you know I
think the period for air strikes is
relatively over I mean the threats to
the citizens is a bit more updated and
so we should look at the opportunity for
them to dialogue and try and resolve the
issue
otherwise if it continues like this I
mean by the time you know peace returns
that country would have been completely
obliterated now in Cote d'Ivoire
you were very your President issued a
statement and he also said that our
policies of peace he stayed out of Cote
d'Ivoire has that affected your
relationship with terror
no we have a fantastic relation which
could be why is our neighbor and so our
destinies are tied to each other we
would have wished that the issue was
resolved more amicably and peacefully
rather than through the force of arms
unfortunately the resolution eventually
came through you know fighting and so we
think that Cote d'Ivoire has the
opportunity to make a fresh start and a
lot to depend on what our government you
know he needs to reach out and create a
government of national unity and start a
healing process in code avoir codifies
problems
have an ethnic and religious dimension
and I think that how president whatever
handles it going forward is going to be
important
Ghana our president was at his
inauguration and we placed any support
they wanted to help you know could've
won you know become the nation that it
was once again living at peace with
itself and developing the quality of
lives of its people
and finally globalization has been very
positive for Ghana overall I think
especially because given Ghana's natural
resources gold cocoa and now oil it is
must be doing pretty well within the
given market of commodity prices rising
now as you have said yourself that
having these natural uses could also be
cars so how do you hope to prevent Ghana
becoming like another Nigeria with with
a lot of resources but lot of problem as
well how do you avoid that we have been
very lucky especially with the oil and
gas industry because of the timing at
which we discovered you know Ghana's oil
and gas potential has given us the
opportunity to learn from the best
experiences and from the west
experiences and let me say on record
that both experiences I mean countries
that have gone through both experiences
have been very generous in sharing the
experience with us countries like Norway
you know which are some of the best
practices in how to manage an oil and
gas industry have been absolutely
absolutely fantastic in assisting Ghana
to develop our legislation and so on and
so forth and countries like Nigeria
which have had you know not good so good
experiences with oil have also been
fantastic and generous in sharing their
experience with us we've had several
Nigerian resource people come and talk
at oil and gas conferences in Ghana and
analyse you know what you know problems
they went through and all that and I
don't absolutely blame them Nigeria had
nobody to learn from they discovered oil
and gas in the 19th
there were no other African countries or
other developing countries that I've had
this resource and so they've had to
learn from their own experience and
develop their own experience you know
but I must say that they have made quite
rapid progress they have a strong local
industry that services the oil and gas
industry that we don't have in Ghana you
know and so they are telling us look at
local content look at local content
because you must increase the multiplier
effect of the industry in your economy
it's not enough to just get the money
from the oil sales and all that and
develop huge infrastructure but how you
integrates the industry backwards into
your economy is critical and so that's
one red flag decreed for us and so right
at the beginning of the industry we are
passing a look of content bill that
forces the oil companies to look for
expertise locally so that's a good thing
but all you know I mean we do have a lot
of Natural Resources bauxite manganese
you know gold you know and cocoa and so
on and so forth
one of the things we want to avoid is
the Dutch disease so that oil does not
become like the dominant you know sector
of economy and that we channel some of
the oil resources into keeping
agriculture active ensuring food
security for Ghana and so on and so
forth so we've learned from those also
have I think said that you are going to
and here too the extractive industries
transparency initiative
yeah and Ghana is an active member we do
regular assessments to ensure that these
things are being you know applied in in
a transparent manner and so on and so
forth we have regular review teams and
so on and so Ghana is committed to that
and we will uphold it
one advantage Ghana has in all this is
that we have a free society people are
free to criticize we have a vibrant
media that you know is free to write
anything at once and I think that those
are the guarantees you need you know to
ensure transparency going forward on
that very positive note mr. president
thank you very much for talking to us
thank you very much thanks for having me